pactiv mon petit bac amoureux y avait
personne dans la puce il aura les belles
personnes dans le bateau bah du coup les
bixi c'est un truc de ouf quoi à dos au
lit vous vous décrivez comme humoriste
improvisateurs flûtiste parfois flûtiste
nasale ça c'est une radio gags parce
qu'on venait d'une famille de musiciens
alors qu'en 2000 que vous faites le saut
je vais être papa maman je dois être
humoriste ça doit être difficile annonce
ici même il ya fallu que je fasse mon
coming out je ne serai pas musicien mais
sans farce
toute ma famille a bien pris mais mme
peuhmond du moins on s'en doutait c'est
qu'est-ce que tu attendais et je m'en
tire parce que vous étiez comique dans
la vie de tous les jours un peu un brin
jambages aime bien taquiner mon prochain
tir et la paix pas qu'il veut bien
regarder vos parents mais toujours dans
le respect de l'autre ouais mais le rêve
pour moi c'est comme essentielle à
n'importe quelle relation que j'ai je
suis entouré de gens drôles et puis qui
aimerait plus que tout je me rends
compte que toute ma vie toutes mes
relations significatives sont articulées
autour du principe qu'il faut ré fausse
amusé quand même en 2015 et un tellement
d'humoristes au québec mais il y en a
qui ont fait des qualifiables de
l'humour ce que vous n'avez pas fait
parce que j'avais un peu les 14000
d'europe pour faire l'écho nationale
mais comment voulez vous vous démarquez
ben moi ça a été de passer beaucoup par
justement mon background plus musical et
visuel j'avais la possibilité par des
vidéos des capsules falla propres
montages j'allais poser aussi dans mes
personnages d'un pro j'ai essayé
d'amener un petit mot mon bagage à moi
sur la table puis 1 en jouant avec ça on
a commencé à trouver une identité
humoristique se concentrer à débloquer
il ya pas eu un moment exact et je
dirais que c'est vraiment bien mais
capsules web ou à ce que les gens m'en
parlait de plus en plus il a la flûte
nasa
on a parlé mais c'est resté dans
l'imaginaire collectif un peu un objet
d'unicité de santé
m toujours en train de penser à votre
prochaine capsules vidéo à votre
prochain gamme sur internet comme le
présente manger une bonne idée du caps
n'ont pas toujours mais c'est vrai que
ça peut donner un obsédant parce que
parce qu'on cherche toujours aussi à
recréer un peu les bons coups qu'on a
fait mais je pense que comme toute chose
faut savoir mettre son cerveau à off
je suis curieux de savoir comment ça se
passe est-ce que c'est très spontanée la
façon dont vous faites vos vidéos ou au
contraire c'est très travaillé c'est un
peu des deux je dirais que ça parle
souvent d'une idée vraiment simples
souvent stupides et
j'essaie de l'exécuter avec beaucoup de
soin donc l'angle est peut-être mieux e
mail à la manière dont je la travaille
et soignée et je mets le temps qu'il
faut pour amener l'idée le plus loin
possible c'est un peu ça ma mentalité
vous êtes très populaires sur les
réseaux sociaux cent soixante mille
abonnés sur facebook 159000 sur
instagram le côté obscur réseaux sociaux
à cause de tous ces commentaires et
l'une de vos vidéos sur les antilles
masquer ce qui a fait réagir vous avez
décidé de prendre une pause à l'été
dernier justement pour ça moi mon combo
savate de contaminer mon entourage
aïe mais d'en masquer we must une
victoire est ce que ce sera encore
difficile pour vous de vivre avec tous
ces commentaires à ce que vous nous
censurer flamme que je me sens sur wii
certainement des fois je me dis que
dimanche j'ai pas la force psychologique
ou émotive d'aborder un sujet sachant à
quel point ce qui est en ce moment le
québec est diffusée puis j'ai pas envie
d fois de faire des polémiques pour
faire des polémiques
est-ce que ça m'affecte autant
j'apprends à me trink carapace et à
faire la part des choses
moi j'avais besoin de prendre la
distance autant j'ai été énormément sur
internet autant c'est devenu une
obsession je répondais à tout le monde
puis je vois je me suis vraiment est
garée là dedans au détriment même de mes
proches puis de ma famille à un point
que j'ai décidé de couper ça c'est qu'un
peu comme une désintox et après un mois
sans réseaux sociaux je me suis dis bah
écoutes je pense que je peux réussir à
mettre du bon parce que je crois
foncièrement qu'il ya manière de
s'exprimer sur les réseaux sociaux puis
ça peut ça peut faire du bien aux gens
mais faut être capable de rester
la saison 2 de 3 c'est la saison de trop
vous avez quatre nominations prochain
gala des oliviers dont la nomination
prestigieuse artistes qu'au vu de la
nouaye quoi l'artiste comme je le sais
pas c'est qu'on a parce qu à vis de ce
que je comprends c'est un artiste qui
s'est illustré vraiment spécifiquement
dans le contexte pandémique donc souvent
via les réseaux sociaux fixe habitants
vous pouvez voter pour moi en cliquant
sur le lien juste ici on se souhaite que
ça soit la seule édition de ce prix là
évidemment mais l'ouest pour moi c'est
quand même un bon une bonne tape dans le
dos ce prix là parce qu'un effet je me
suis vraiment quand même forcé à donner
du contenu de qualité pendant la
pandémie pardoux celui je vous dis le
mot de cambronne pour le gala des
oliviers et je ne dois pas de dire merci
semblent au vert pour ne pas
quand j'ai le mauvais sens en son temps
non plus seulement plus le son en but
mais le temps que le train peu de temps